welcome back time for the fastest social
media ruins everything residents of a
beautiful Vermont town are trying to ban
the Swarms of selfie taking influencers
who invade their town during Peak Fall
Foliage times folks there just plain
tired of trespassers on their private
property it is a private residence and
there is no parking area there's none of
that here they are walking on the lawn
the property to take their photo shoots
we asked them not to fly their drones
over us
seems like a great Clash of Freedom
lovers and freedom protectors what do
you think what do you think no it is and
it's private property the first thing
you do is you charge them with criminal
trespass if they create any problem or
any with your lawn or anything else is
criminal mischief I mean why they want
to pass an ordinance stopping them from
coming into town that would be that's
what I'm talking about Freedom you can't
stop somebody no they can't do that but
you can certainly stop you know the
woman who bought Walter White's house
breaking bad she apparently should
Google this she apparently yells at
everybody they come by she sits there
ready to scream at them do you know this
woman
[Laughter]
Jessie
I would have taken my nephew sent him
out there maybe have him bring some
friends and have them start charging 20
a car to park there
that's an obvious solution to the
problem make money from them good old
American capitalists I actually think
though but private property if it's your
private property why not a citizen's
arrest
and then take a picture of that and put
that on Instagram and then put it on
YouTube and then make a lot of money
that way
exclamation point but yeah as usual I
didn't read the story I thought
these were Vermont
Vermont influencers so I just assumed it
was a Holstein
you have that thing that button you
could push hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now